i don't think it'll be cancelled it's
going to be a challenge we know that
it's pretty self-evident um and
there will be adaptations but look
of all the countries on the planet that
really has the fortitude the resilience
and the street smarts to see this
through it is actually japan
i wake up as a federation president
pretty grateful
that it's japan that's dealing with this
and not some other places that i can
think of
so i i'm sure we will be there i think
there will be big issues around crowds
and socially distancing
the athletes i mean just think about the
village you've got ten and a half
thousand athletes probably another seven
thousand support staff in there
and they're all probably wanting to eat
at roughly the same time you know and
that's just a sliver
of the challenge so look i think for the
athletes it will be a very different
experience
but what do we have we have two
ingredients we have the broadcasters we
have the athletes that want to be there
um and look we want passionate crowds in
the stadium but we also have to
recognize
uh the a very very small percentage of
people watching the games are watching
it in the stadium
uh so let's i think that the games will
take place but i think they will look
different